was dr alan stills the nfl's chief
medical officer this is pftpm
i wasn't planning to add anything beyond
our interview with
dr sill 16 minutes decent length but
i wanted to answer some questions today
i know it's been a while since we've
done that and also
there's some news a little friday
afternoon news dumpage from the nfl
we've been waiting and waiting and
waiting
for the league to do something with
antonio brown
you know my feelings on it i have had a
very strong conviction that the league
has
taken full advantage of its ability
under the personal conduct policy to
drag its feet which it's done for 11
months
with three different incidents involving
antonio brown that have not
been resolved well as of today they are
resolved according to nfl media which
is the nfl two of the three incidents
are
covered by an eight-game suspension that
was levied by the league
now by way of a refresher first incident
an accusation of sexual assault and rape
made in a lawsuit filed last september
second incident a claim made by a woman
regarding a completely separate incident
that antonio brown harassed her via text
message
after she went public to si.com with her
concerns
third incident the felony arrest of
antonio brown
after an altercation with a moving truck
driver reportedly because brown didn't
want to pay the bill
for the items that were being delivered
to his home in south florida he has
since pleaded no contest
to felony charges so that's the one that
was most clear
on the t for punishment because the base
fully and finally resolved nothing
further to be investigated nothing
further for the nfl to do
now according to nfl media again which
is the nfl
the eight-game suspension covers the
altercation with the moving truck driver
and the allegation made
by the woman who claims she was harassed
by antonio brown
after raising some concerns to si.com
the original incident the one that got
all of this started
that incident still unresolved by the
nfl
and i get the impression based upon the
reporting from
nfl media i.e the nfl that the league is
going to wait and see what happens in
the civil lawsuit before making a
decision
on whether or not antonio brown should
be disciplined for
that claim now even though it's not a
criminal case
the claim made in this civil lawsuit is
a serious one
sexual assault and rape and if the
league believes
antonio brown raped the woman that's
suing him for sexual assault and rape
he should never play in the nfl again
so when you consider the nfl's had a
chance to interview her
a chance to interview him chance to do
whatever other investigation it needs to
do
it doesn't have to wait for the civil
lawsuit to be resolved make a decision
he did it or he didn't do it see i think
the nfl is concerned about the
possibility
that the league would find that he
didn't do it
and then there'd be a verdict in a civil
lawsuit at some point down the road that
he did do it the nfl would look foolish
finding he's blameless but then having a
jury find
that oh by the way we believe he
committed sexual assault
and or rape but in this setting
i don't know that waiting makes a whole
lot of sense
when you're not talking about a criminal
case you're talking about a civil claim
with a low standard it goes one way or
the other it depends upon who the jury
believes
the nfl needs to decide who it believes
the nfl has had the opportunity to speak
to the people involved the nfl has had
an opportunity to come to a conclusion
come to a conclusion put this behind
everyone
he did it or he didn't do it if you
believe him don't suspend him for it
clear him of it move forward if you
don't believe him
then you believe he committed rape then
tell him he can never play in the nfl
again
period the other thing that's embedded
in this
and i assume based upon the way this has
happened
that he won't land on the commissioner
exempt list if he's signed
but the nfl seems to be
acknowledging that the claim of sexual
assault and rape made in a civil setting
is not enough standing alone
to result in antonio brown being placed
on paid leave
because that climb is still out there
now i don't know whether they just don't
want to
focus on that to crystallize and
articulate exactly
what this suspension means if again the
report from nfl media
which is the nfl is accurate that only
two of the three claims have been
resolved
but this doughnut hole is
just strange that you've made the guy
wait for this long that he served a
14-game
unpaid suspension because no team was
going to
sign him and risk having to pay him not
to play because of the belief he would
have been put on the commissioner exempt
list
well now we resolve two of the three
claims the one that's left
is the claim for sexual assault rape and
he's apparently not going to be put on
the commissioner example list if he's
signed
unless somebody gets the ultimate
surprise
where they sign antonio brown the league
says all right the eight-game suspension
applies and then he can play for you the
eight-game suspension comes and goes
he gets ready to play and the league
says well you know what we're gonna put
him on the commissioner exempt list
because of the unresolved claim of
sexual assault and rape this is an
unresolved claim of sexual assault and
rape
either resolve it or acknowledge
we can't resolve it and
i don't know what you do if you and i
mean at that that see
i really think that this is all driven
by the concern
that if the league were to exonerate him
if the league were to find he didn't
commit sexual assault and or rape and if
the league concluded that i don't know
why he ever plays
if you find you didn't do it and a civil
jury
proves you wrong then you have an even
bigger
pr mess and make no mistake about it
this entire
mechanism is driven by pr it's not
driven by
some sense of justice and fairness and
we're going to do the right thing and
we're going to supplement the justice
system and we have our own in-house
justice system to deal with
no this entire effort to police the
private lives of players
is about pr it's about having guys
employed who have been accused of doing
horrible things while not at work
and it was supplemented six years ago
with the opportunity to put the players
on paid leave
when the allegations are so
strong that they can't have the guy
around
and you know the league's position on
all of this is that
it's not punishment to put a gun on paid
leave which is completely misguided
because players want to play football of
course it's punishment to not let
someone play and just pay their salary
it's a cynical view of how players
operate
i just look i'm glad they've finally
done something
but they still have left a major
question unresolved and who knows
when it will be resolved but apparently
they're not going to put them on the
commissioner exempt list
and now someone can sign him so who's
going to sign it the two leading
candidates seem to be the seahawks and
the ravens
i continue
the ravens don't really want to sign him
but they don't want to tell him no
because they don't want to give him
reason
to poison his cousin marquis hollywood
brown against
the team for which marquis hollywood
brown
plays so you kind of hold him at arm's
length
you don't say yes you don't say no and
you wait and you hope and you pray
that the seahawks give the guy a job
because
if you tell him no he isn't going to be
happy obviously
sign him and it goes sideways and you
have to cut him
he's not going to be happy so you know
it's just one of those
strange awkward things for the ravens
where i think they don't want him
just yesterday john harbaugh the coach
of the team said i don't even think he's
available beside now well he was he
always has been
available to be signed the concern was
if you sign him
he lands on the commissioner exemplist
now some clarity
if you sign him he can be with you for
training camp and then when training
camp ends
and the week one preparations begin in
earnest
that's when he begins his eight-game
suspension apparently
without fear of being placed on the
commission or exempt list but
with possibility hovering that if and
when
the civil lawsuit is resolved there will
be another
punishment imposed by the league
if i were antonio brown i would do
what should have been done a long time
ago
what should have been done before that
lawsuit was even filed
write the check to settle
the case whatever it takes make that
case go away should have done it before
it was ever filed
should definitely do it now because if
he wants to come back and play in the
nfl
you don't want to have this hanging over
you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports